this is a production of Cornell
University
danuel feature the Liberty hide Bailey
lecture features distinguished faculty
from the College of Agriculture and life
sciences who will be discussing their
work which also highlights key priority
areas for the college the lectures
namesake and that is Liberty High Bailey
was the very first Dean of Cornell's New
York State College of Agriculture after
that College was established by the New
York State Legislature in 1904 and for
those of you who would like a little
piece of trivia the iconic Bailey Hall
across the street is named after Dean
Liberty High Bailey now Liberty High
Bailey had a remarkable career the
breadth and the diversity of that career
which mirrors that of cows even to this
day Bailey was a botanist and a plant
breeder who played a crucial role in the
development of the field of
horticultural science in addition to
that though he was a writer an editor a
poet a rural sociologist a philosopher a
traveler and an environmentalist in his
honor today's panel presentation is
entitled from farm to fork how cals is
leading the food revolution our College
is a strong leader in the food space
because as with Liberty High Bailey the
college has incredible breadth of
expertise our knowledge base supports
all stages of food production from basic
to translational research to an
extension network that puts our
groundbreaking discoveries into the
hands and the fields of growers and
consumers across New York State and well
beyond whether it's breeding tastier
vegetables and disease resistant fruits
whether it's improving the quality and
the safety of our dairy products or
supporting new crop markets that can
thrive on the East Coast our researchers
are demonstrating just how central this
College is to the food revolution both
in New York State and around the world
and not to that end I would like to
introduce to you today's panelists and
I'll start with Thomas Bjorkman who was
a professor of horticulture and the
school of integrative plant science
Thomas earned his bachelor's degree from
the University of California Davis and
his PhD from Cornell plant biology
program after conducting postdoctoral
studies on the west coast
Thomas returned to Cornell in 1990
joining the horticultural Sciences
Department on Cornell's Geneva campus
Thomas works on many aspects of plant
development that affect the productivity
the quality the sustainability and the
profitability of New York grown
vegetables he directs the eastern
broccoli project which seeks to create a
reliable high-quality year-round supply
of Eastern grown broccoli for East Coast
markets our next panelist is Michael
Mazurek Michael a plant breeder
is the Calvin Noyes kini professor of
plant breeding at Cornell University he
received his PhD from Cornell in 2008
michael's vegetable breeding program
uses traditional methods of cross
pollination to develop new cultivars of
squash peppers and many other vegetables
for organic farming systems his process
is informed by surveys of the natural
diversity by studies of the underlying
genetics that allow adaptation of the
plant material is naturally managed
ecosystems he selects the traits that
that he's looking for in the plants both
by what is in demand by growers and by
consumers so for example the grower
driven traits that interest Michael
focus on fungal and insect resistances
that will work in regionally adapted
backgrounds to provide a reliable and a
productive harvest on the consumer side
his consumer driven traits focus on
color quality flavor and novelty to
drive the consumption of naturally
nutritious food
our next panelist is Carmen Marrero and
Carmen is a professor in the Department
of Food Science she earned her
bachelor's and PhD degrees in food
engineering from the University of
galati
in Romania Carmen's research and
teaching interests are in the areas of
physical and engineering properties of
food of dairy food processing and food
safety engineering she is specifically
interested in developing and optimizing
novel food processing methods to enhance
food safety quality and product
shelf-life she also is working on
developing microbial repellents surfaces
and on understanding and controlling the
intermolecular interactions and
structural transformations that occur
during the processing of food our final
panelist is Cortney Weber who is a
professor in the horticulture section of
the School of integrative plant science
Cortney grew up on a dairy farm in
central Illinois and he earned his
Bachelor of Science from the University
of Illinois but his MS NS PhD both from
the University of Florida Courtney has
worked at Cornell for 18 years in berry
breeding and genetics specifically
working on strawberries raspberries and
blackberries and really good stuff yeah
his research uses genomics and molecular
markers to examine genetics and the
inheritance of disease resistance
he holds patents on seven berry
varieties that have four strawberries
and three raspberries and he has an
eighth patent that is under preparation
for the archer strawberry which is his
newest variety which was just released
in 2016 and now finally I would like to
introduce today's moderator and that is
Chris smart Chris smart is the interim
director of the School of integrative
plant science and she's also a professor
of plant pathology she earned her
bachelor's and PhD from Michigan State
University her research seeks to develop
improved management strategies for
vegetable diseases by increasing our
understanding of pathogen biology and
the diversity of those pathogens under
field condition
using this information she provides
growers with novel disease management
options while also promoting sustainable
agricultural practices
Chris's outreach efforts also involve
developing partnerships between Cornell
University and elementary school
educators and students to help increase
student awareness of agriculture and so
now I would like to turn the program
over to Chris smart and our panelists
thank you well Thank You Dean Bohr it's
a pleasure for me to moderate the
Liberty high bailey panel today it's
really nice for me actually my daughter
Stephanie smart just completed her
freshman year here at Cornell and while
you may have noticed from my bio that I
have no Cornell connections other than
my marriage my husband Larry Smart has a
30th reunion this year he is a professor
in plant breeding and genetics and got
his undergraduate bachelor's degree here
in 1987
Larry's mom Marjorie smart got her
bachelor's degree from Cornell in 1957
so this year is her 60th reunion
Marjorie's mother it was pretty cool the
family I married into Florence Nelson
got her a bachelor's degree from Cornell
in 1927 so it's really cool that my
daughter can be this fourth generation
not just a cornelian but a strong
tradition of women and education at
Cornell and it's exciting for me to be a
part of that so this year this view
engineer is really special for us so
enough about my family history I do want
to say that the plant and food science
at Cornell has never been more vibrant
nor has it been more important to our
local communities and to people across
the globe excuse me as dean Bohr
mentioned I'm the interim director of
the school of integrative plant science
and that brings together hundreds of
scientists who are researching teaching
and extending information about plants
and the soils in which they grow our
research in sips or the School of
Integrative plant science spread the
breadth of topics from fundamental plant
science how our leaves forms how do
flowers form all the way to solving
problems for agricultural producers here
in New York and around the world today
we're going to hear about some of the
work that people faculty members in the
school of integrated plant science have
combined with others across cals
including Carmen to bring healthy safe
and nutritious foods from our farms to
our tables each of our panel members
will speak for about 10 minutes and then
we'll move on to the next panel member
after the fourth panel member has spoken
then we'll open up the floor for
questions
we'll begin today with Michael Mazurek
who is a professor in plant breeding and
genetics this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu